hi welcome to this week's episode of
cold fusion
i've got an exciting announcement to
make at the end of this video so be sure
to stick around for that
this week we'll be talking about neural
link we'll cover the updates of the
neural link device working in animals
but will also take a deeper look into
neural incorporation and what's been
happening behind the scenes
according to ex-employees there's been
some conflict within the neural link
company walls
so let's get into it you are watching
cold fusion tv
so starting with a quick overview and
recap neural link is a brain machine
interface
that will be connected to the brain soft
tissue via a thousand tiny wires
these tiny wires are connected and
inserted into the brain by a robot that
can be likened onto a sewing machine
according to early animal testing these
implants don't cause any bleeding or
noticeable trauma on the soft tissue
future patients should be up and out of
the hospital within a few hours
and there's no need for general
anesthesia the medium-term
aim of the neural link product is to
bring to market a device which can help
with
certain severe brain injuries
the end result will be allowing
paraplegics to regain motor function
make the blind see again or even help
with anxiety
so here's a quick overview of how it
works
this device with the help of algorithms
is able to send voltages to the brain
and receive voltages from the brain in
other words
the neural link is able to read and
write to the brain
i've already done an episode explaining
how this works
and the technical details behind it it's
an absolutely fascinating watch if
you've missed it i'll leave a link below
recently the research team took to the
stage to give some updates
overall the updates covered things like
clarifying security concerns
and also how they're making animal
testing ethical and some other things
but probably the most notable was the
demonstration of the long-term use of a
neural link in a pig for the past two
months and counting
they demonstrated the implant sensing
pulses from the brain whenever the pig
snout touched something
they outputted this information in the
form of audio beeps
[Applause]
and the this neural link is implanted in
the region
of the brain that are where the snout
snout is located which is actually quite
a large part of greg's brain
and there was a particularly interesting
showcase beyond this
the team could take readings from
neurons and use this information
with the help of on-board algorithms to
predict how the pig's legs are going to
be moving
from there the research team were able
to compare the predicted motion
with the measured motion of the pig and
the results were very consistent
this demonstrates that the neuralink
chip can potentially understand the
motion of joints just
by reading input signals from the brain
obviously this could be very useful in
controlling the movement of limbs
this new version of the neural link is
smaller than version 1
shown last year and will be inductively
charged
according to an employee during the
question and answer session
the device shares some hardware
components with some other high volume
tech like smart watches and smartphones
this means that the final cost will be
within the realm of a few thousand
dollars
it was also revealed that the neural
link corporation had been granted
fda approval under the breakthrough
therapy designation
at this point it should be noted that
neural link as a concept
isn't some far out wacky idea as
described in the previous episode
it's a decades-old technology in the
field of brain machine interface
research
even as far back as 2006 people with
spinal cord paralysis
were able to play pong just by using
their mind after receiving a brain
implant
since then researchers have continued to
explore ways to use computers to improve
brain function
neural link just aims to do this with
much higher precision
and orders of magnitude better
performance
behind the scenes however things have
been a little less smooth
a report by the stat publication has
revealed years of internal conflict
there is a clash within the neurolink
corporation as to how it should be run
on the one hand it seems like a
rapid-paced high-tech company
but on the other hand it's a scientific
research company that really has to wait
for the slow nature of scientific
discovery
unsurprisingly this has caused some
friction
four former employees who wish to remain
anonymous told the stat publication of a
chaotic
internal nature since its founding in
neuralink corporation has lost most of
its founding original scientists
the number has gone from eight to three
these included leading experts
and rising stars in brain machine
interface research
some had previously worked with
pioneering teams at places
such as ibm mit and stanford university
one former employee stated quote they
are building a medical device and
surgical approach to implant that
medical device
and they're approaching it with the use
of a high-tech company
move fast and break things end quote
an example of this for neural link
happened in 2017
the company pushed forward with an
effort to implant 10 000 electrodes on
an array
into the brain of a sheep in one single
procedure
according to a former employee instead
of first trying steps such as
implementing a smaller number of
electrodes
they went in full guns blazing and the
experiment failed
the company has had its fair share of
internal strife
neural links mechanical engineers have
sometimes been at odds with its academic
neuroscientists over the company's
strategy
engineers naturally think very different
to neuroscientists but in some cases
they were even pitted against each other
by leadership
elon predictably sided with the
engineers whenever this happened
it's interesting to note that although
elon musk is the majority owner and
founder of the company
jared bertral is actually the ceo
within the company when certain projects
ran into roadblocks
employees were encouraged to abandon
them and then move on to starting new
ones
according to insiders such issues arose
from the company aiming too broadly and
lacking focus on simpler but more
targeted applications
timelines were also rushed while
scientists often
stressed that research might take months
they were sometimes only given weeks to
complete certain projects
this all gives me flashbacks to my
episode on the behind the scenes
development for the original iphone
just the reality of trying to develop a
groundbreaking product but in an
environment that was a complete pressure
cooker
despite this several former employees
stressed that they did not want to imply
that new ruling corporation was
underperforming
they actually praised the company for
casting a spotlight on the field
they also said musk always operates with
accelerated timelines and a hefty dose
of chaos
a strategy that has enabled him to
successfully transform the space
industry and the automobile market
where others have failed they see the
chaotic nature
as natural for a company with such
ambitious end goals
and credit where credit is due outside
independent researchers
are impressed by some of neurolink's
engineering accomplishments
the sewing machine robot that implants
those thousands of tiny electrodes into
the brain
has been hailed as a great achievement
neurobiologist andrew schwartz of the
university of pittsburgh
a pioneer in the field states quote
overall the concept is impressive and so
is the progress that they've made
end quote according to two former
neurolink employees
the robotic implanting device cost
between 10 million and 20 million
dollars in initial investments
this includes research and development
subsequent robots cost up to five
hundred thousand dollars to build
and the neuralink corporation has
already constructed close to a dozen
musk has poured 100 million dollars into
the project overall
and will continue to pour more into it
according to a former employee
[Music]
so as for neuralink it seems that they
did get off to a rough start according
to former employees and founding
scientists
and i wouldn't be surprised if these
conflicts are still in place today
it's hard to balance the fast pace of
tech development with the slow
and cautious nature of medical science
regardless
the company seems to be making progress
even if it's unlikely that they'll meet
their deadline
of human trials by the end of the year
so the question remains can the
neuralink corporation
achieve the medium-term goal of
restoring motion
sight and much more like memory and
hearing loss
depression seizures strokes and brain
damage
maybe so but first they need to keep the
internal company structure under control
it's impossible to say from the outside
if the company culture has improved
but even if it is perfect today they're
still not out of the woods
once the internal cultural issue is
overcome the company still needs to push
forward
major scientific and medical advances as
there's still
so much about the mind that medical
science doesn't understand yet
however if neural link can achieve all
of this at an affordable price point
it could help millions and as elon has
stated
there could be more on the horizon like
telepathy memory repositories
superhuman vision and of course
interfacing with artificial intelligence
though as the saying goes you must crawl
before you run
no matter the outcome as matt angle ceo
of paradromix
a competitor to neural link states quote
this could be a chance for neuralink to
put on stage
some of the things that everyone in the
neuroscience community knows as possible
but many people in the general public
don't know as possible
if elon can get more attention for this
field and get people really excited
i think the rising tide floats all ships
so what do you guys think are you for a
device like the neural link do you think
musk and his team can pull it off
or are you more skeptical or are you of
the view that technology like this
shouldn't even exist
i'll leave that for you guys to discuss
in the comments section below
check out the previous episode i did on
neuralink so you can get a full
understanding and detailed overview of
the technology
how it works and its plans for future
uses
a lot of you have been asking for years
so i'm finally doing it
i'm finally releasing cold fusion merch
this is going to be a special first
edition limited run
each shirt and hoodie will have my
signature on it i'll be sending out
custom voice messages to as many of you
as i can
just as a thank you you also receive two
unreleased tracks from my upcoming ep
nostalgia dreams
[Music]
this first edition will last for seven
days and then that's it
so if you do want to support the channel
and keep it going check out the links
below
anyway if you'd like to see anything on
science technology business or history
feel free to subscribe to cole fusion my
name is digogo and you've been watching
cold fusion
i'll see you again next week for the
next episode cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's me thinking
you